and we're going to go ahead and get some
questions from the live studio audience
here on the dean show follow me
all right it's not the oprah show this
is the gene show
and we have our brother
mujahid please step up here
got a question for david uh yes david
um within the 50 years as
as i hear you have extensive history in
regards to
speaking to people about god and the
message of god
how did that differ whenever you
embraced islam
um it's very rare that we actually see
muslims going to places and
you know knocking on people's doors or
kind of doing the sort of
kind of evangelical work let's say do
you find that
it's a bit different now to talk about
god or the format
and not necessarily going to the people
maybe like you had in the past how how
did that change how do you deal with
that now
a big difference if you're going to be
like a
christian missionary or a preacher and
that's
that sort of thing when you talk about
god you're primarily
talking to people because you want to
get them into heaven because you want
them to believe
in the divine sacrifice of god's divine
son when you're talking to people in
islam
you're trying to uh tell them the
message of all the prophets which is
also the message of
jesus that they should make god central
to their life
and they should show or prove it by
taking care of their fellow human being
and you would then when you
talk about islam you simply tell them
that essentially what you have in islam
is you have a tried and proven living
community that has done just that that
has a record of how to do that
and that is what you speak about when
you speak about islam
thank you we're going to move on to the
next question
young young brother please come up step
up here and go ahead and ask your
question
to uh david go ahead all right islam
welcome
um i heard there is an old testament uh
recording that says to tell to be able
to distinguish a true
prophet and a false prophet and uh that
a false prophet
or will be the one who tells false
prophecies they prophesize about some of
it doesn't come true
now so we have this issue or this
conflict of the teachings of paul
and jesus christ peace be upon him
what are some of the prophecies of paul
and
did they come true okay
essentially at some time during jesus's
time on earth his ministry he came to
the conclusion that israel was not going
to accept him as their messiah
and he then said according to say
matthew 21 43 that
god's kingdom would be taken from
israel and would be given to another
nation or another community
that in fact would do what they're told
to do now
paul who would either was either who was
a jewish scholar
or partisan or a zealot this didn't go
down very well with them
according to the record as one finds it
in the new testament he first was a
persecutor people who followed jesus
then
he had a nervous breakdown and after his
nervous breakdown he said that jesus
came to him
in a series of visions and dreams and he
told them
you know his message and you find that
in this message
you have a different jesus from all the
indications of the jesus
who actually walked the earth now
paul the thing remember about paul is
that paul said everything he taught or
preached or believed or said or did
came from jesus now uh in two occasions
for example uh book of first corinthians
chapter seven
paul tells the people that jesus jesus's
time when he's going to be coming back
is so short it doesn't matter that if
they
rejoice don't rejoice marry marry or
don't marry uh
buy or or don't buy it doesn't matter
now this is 1900 years ago this didn't
happen
you find in the fourth chapter of first
thessalonians that he was telling his
audience the people from tesla
that before everybody there was dead
jesus was coming back this didn't happen
now remember he said that jesus told him
everything that would happen in the
future
and paul certainly at some time during
his
lifetime believe that jesus was god so
paul was saying that
god told him this and that it didn't
happen so either you should believe
god told him this or that is paul making
a mistake
and where this is a test of a prophet
is you'll find in deuteronomy chapter
18 it says that a prophet if he's
if he speaks in the name of god and he
tells you something's going to happen it
doesn't happen
it's it's a false prophet giving a false
prophecy and don't listen to him
here in texas thank you very much and
we're going to go to the next we have
time for one more question young man
young man please come up and ask your
question
wait hold on before you start see we're
in texas i haven't heard nobody say
y'all
no it'll happen go ahead how are you
doing no
yes um you mentioned earlier that some
people may see
throughout your your time as a muslim
that people have seen islam to be
foreign
what are some things that you think that
practices that muslims muslims can
undergo
in order to eliminate that or
what have you seen through your
lifestyle that muslims have practiced or
that the perception have been from
non-muslims concerning this
okay uh the question of perception is
you uh
you you have a community that is
distinct
or different and muslims uh
should just simply concentrate on being
if they're distinct or different and
being distinct or different
in a good way which is what muslims are
supposed to do
supposed to make god central to life and
take care of their fellow human being
and as long as they practice that
they're fine
thank you very much and that is
it for now we're going to take a break
and we're going to be back
with more here live the dean show
in texas y'all sit tight
i am not afraid i am not afraid to stand
alone
if allah
[Music]
i am not afraid to stand alone
and if we're going to worship something
i figured i might as well worship the
creator
instead of any of the creations now
upon investigating all the religions i
remember finding out the meaning of what
islam is what a muslim is
those who surrender their self to god is
a muslim
those who surrender submit to god god's
will
that is it islam was pure it was just
you just pray to god your creators
back here on the dean show live in texas
and we're here with david the author of
the last christian
we have a few more minutes before the
show comes to a
end and i have just a few more points i
want to cover did you get a chance to
watch these
senate hearings with the pepe king peter
king uh only for a few minutes
yeah i really didn't get to watch that
much of it they were
coming together discussing the
radicalization of youth
so basically when you see some of the
politicians
who are really supposed to be working to
create understanding you know between
the people bringing people together
but we really want the politicians and
people out there to understand us better
because maybe they have good intentions
but
they they're misunderstanding us okay so
here's here's what i or what i would say
yeah uh
the question is about whether muslims
are or not good citizens
the constitution defines what a good
citizen is and the preamble says
we the people of the united states in
order to form a more perfect union
to establish justice ensure domestic
tranquility
to provide for the common defense to
promote the general welfare
to uh secure for ourselves from our
posterity
the blessings of liberties do establish
and ordain this constitution united
states
any emotion that can say that is a good
muslim and most muslims can say that
most
muslims
will embrace that most muslims are good
americans
that's right i like that masha allah
so before we come to an end tell us now
where can people if they want to read
your book the last christian
where can i get this okay uh
uh simply remember the title last
question go online
you can go to either amazon.com or
barnes and noble
the people who actually publish this
book are author house like i'm the
author and i live in a house author
house
go online they sell the book as well
they also sell it as an ebook
hopefully a texas company texas global
traders will also soon be selling the
book
but remember my name david gullion and
the title last christian
and you can simply buy it online it'd be
the quickest easiest way to do it
i'd like to thank you and any closing
comments for those who are out there
and the way of life that they're living
they're not happy with it it's confusing
and and they want to step out of the
confusion and they're just a little bit
timid you know
culture class sometimes they see muslims
as people who
they just can't identify with but they
can identify with islam
what advice do you have for them
islam if it's practiced the way it's
supposed to be
means peace it also means the best form
of life
in others if a person makes god the
center of their life
and by doing so they take care of their
fellow human being they make the world a
better place
and that is what islam is all about
thank you very much thank you very much
may god almighty the creator reward you
for being with us thank you so much and
thank you
again for tuning in to another episode
of the dean show you might not like
spicy food
neither do i you might not like dressing
a certain way you like
dressing your way as long as this is a
modest way don't worry about it
you can do it in islam it's all good as
long as it's pleasing to the creator of
the heavens and the earth and as
you heard our guests say making god the
central point in your life
just worshiping god not worshiping jesus
not worshiping
statues icons idols monkeys elephants
none of these things only worshiping the
creator
and doing good doing good to your
neighbor doing good to your parents
doing good to your fellow brothers and
sisters in humanity
this is what islam is about and you met
an american
you met an american we've interviewed
romanians hispanics
islam is the fastest growing way of life
in the world and thank you for coming
to the source to learn about the most
misunderstood yet fastest growing way of
life in the world
islam practiced by over 1.5 billion and
you could be a muslim too
you can be a muslim too because a muslim
is simply one who takes that free choice
that they have
of either submitting to the creation of
god or submitting to god
and you know what the right thing to do
is submit to the one jesus submitted to
that's the one god the one creator and
do good deeds do righteousness and this
is what islam is calling you to
get a free copy of the quran call the
number on the screen 1-800-662-islam
read the verbatim word of god and
continue to come back here to the dean
show until next time we started with
people
we end with peace peace be unto you come
and see
what everyone's talking about if you
find one contradiction it can't be from
god
but the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best give up
worship
god is one i will never give up spending
this message i hope that you take that
necessary step you don't know if you're
gonna live until tomorrow
so you gotta find that urgency to do the
right thing right now
if you say that you do not believe in
jesus you have stepped outside of islam
you cannot be a muslim it
attended our faith too
it's cold it's late